c'est tout simplement un scandale dans
la mesure où il ya un nombreuses
nombreuses personnes qui sans qu'ils
sont libérés aujourd'hui au royaume uni
et à que running
je voulais un singe en plus depuis les
le dernier rapport des nations unies on
sait qu'il est dans une situation assez
fragile on sait qu'il est qui traversent
des périodes de santé qui est compliqué
et il faisait partie des personnes qui
étaient susceptibles de pouvoir sortir
pour des raisons de santé et donc le
fait de laisser à l'intérieur pour nous
est un vrai scandale mais un scandale
humanitaire surtout soutenue en dehors
du fait que c'est un scandale politique
et ça on le dit depuis un moment mais la
sarre adresse scandale humanitaire dans
ce qu'on est en train de laisser
quelqu'un mourir à petit feu dans une
prison et on sait très bien pour avoir
eu j'ai eu son père encore récemment on
sait très bien que j'ai eu un sens il
attrape le coronavirus malheureusement
il n'aura à mon avis déjà pas les soins
nécessaires et dans un deuxième temps il
aura des grosses difficultés pour s'en
sortir parce que ça sentait vraiment
chancelante en tant qu ennemi public
numéro 1 on est fait aucun cadeau
puisque julian assange a bien entendu
d'autres informations sous le coude et
il est clair qu'ils que si on lui laisse
la liberté il
il redonnera d'autres vérités il re
publiera d'autres informations